alrighty d 4 i'm playing like a world
champion that's something we haven't
seen we have not seen the dutch the
dutch with c4 few cattle feeding cattle
time Leningrad variation is what they're
calling it is that the truth are they
lying there on chest cube d5 isn't not
afraid of d5 mi let's go night i'll be
playing d5 black plays d5 i have this
they go play d 5 this is square right
here I'm gonna pivot about on that all
right I'm not afraid should I be afraid
maybe I should be afraid
alrighty see takes D all right well why
might I not want to take on D because I
give this Knight to c6 square Mike why
might I want to take a t5 cuz maybe
black takes here and hangs on to it now
let's get rid of that oh you guys can't
see the cursor can you oh I'll have to
fix that let me fix that real quick
thank you yeah I was doing a lot of
playing around he's back the mouse is
back in action you can see him now right
I get some quick confirmation on that
okay
yes the cursors out and about the mouse
is back he's he remains wounded but uh
he's back in action just take here
because I want to play Bishop f4 yeah
get out of there get out I'm gonna play
Bishop f4 temple gainer and I think I
win by force force twin counting the
chickens too early thinks that that is
the case my in early chicken counter mmm
I'm just I'm saying that I don't like I
don't see a winning continuation but
what I am seeing is a very very
difficult road ahead for black because
I'm eliminating this guy and the king is
going to be very weak and I can I guess
I see possibilities of either a good
night versus a bad bishop or a good
versus bad bishop so these things say to
me black is going to be in rough shape
so let me take care first let me post
here and I've pressure on this guy
pawned push here well it's not going to
be a problem it probably is going to be
a problem because now I could play here
and if the Queen grabs my a pond I think
there's going to be a serious serious
beating given out I'm pretty sure at
least because a pig lands on the seventh
a hungry hungry pig my light squared
Bishop could also be doing something
else maybe I could get it back in action
with e3 and weasel around in this
direction
um but this night is a bit of a pain I
just chopped this night and go for a
good versus bad bishop situation
hmm
well let's try
and
she can't be as a kid
uh
this is silly oh well I don't know
there's going to be pressure on my beep
on I have a safer king I might have to
like watch oh I have to babysit the beep
on for a little bit but I'm gonna look
to put pressure on this pond um let's go
clean here
and then what what do you want to do mmm
Oh like those sound effects mmm you know
all right just III and there's no fear
no fear what if there's pressure on the
beep on do I push I think I do oh yeah
now I definitely do because you know one
one thing I would have been hesitant
with with playing be four is if black
had an a5 response but it's not
happening and I just want to make sure
as soon as the Queen oh oh oh I'm
dropping my a pawn queen here I have to
move my rook and then the a pond Falls
but I get this guy I get at very active
and again he's gonna be shaking in his
boots pretty sure let's go here it's got
get out of the trouble so good versus
bad bishop mm-hmm but I'm actually seen
these guys it's just being a exchanged
in fact that's what I'm gonna have to
run with you believe that believe it
believe that one because you know what
this Bishop is the glue he's gluing
everything together I have to get rid of
this clown before my rooks can actually
have a threat I gotta go here
get out of there Bishop now
now what
pile-up on the sea pond triple up on the
sea pun but first get rid of this Queen
because there's only one way that black
can strike at my beep on I want to have
my rook around to watch over that a 5
break so now it starts to show the c6
pond is running very short on defenders
and it can't be supported anymore hit
three defended too and it cannot be
defended anymore I do have to still be
cautious because even though I could end
up with the pond well now I'm probably
an end up with two ponds so I could take
like this I was going to say if we had a
mass amount of exchanges and then I
ended up with like a past a pump if this
works getting behind it it's still
pretty tricky to go ahead and maybe win
we could still see something like that
happen maybe where takes rook takes
Queen takes Queen takes rook takes rook
takes a and I'd like to get behind my
own pond but they get behind it first
let's take care
and let's play here I might have to run
my king over to my a pond
I should probably move faster move
quicker let's do this I'm not sure why
but uh let's do this next oh I gotta go
quicker oh I'm not going quicker come on
let's go go go go go give a check a pig
wild pig I'll pass pond trickiness
everywhere Oh trouble for the king pigs
everywhere there's got to be made around
every corner can't defend everything can
you make one threat that's me there are
too many may there are two too much
stuff going on wild pigs all right good
game action I shouldn't where'd my time
go what it was I am what sort of
position was I chewing on right there
what was I thinking about for so long
good game windmill let me back up let's
flip this board and now if I had to
offer a thing or two it would be that d5
is probably not a good pond move to go
with because of the e5 square really
just being too weak can't do that I
don't think I think the idea here is d6
and if why does not reacting properly
then you could get in an e5 advance and
maybe as a follow-up look to get in
efore and then just kind of slam the
door in my bishop so right here I think
is the main main point it's directed at
particular pond move go with the d6 and
try and get any 5d6 will have to be met
with something like d5 clamping down on
this square but even so you could still
try to get an e5 and they'll be this on
passant and we'll end up with a
different pawn structure but I don't
think d5 is the way to go here it's just
way to weakening of that e5 square and
white really doesn't have any problems
and this guy is backward he's potential
target down the line so okay my main
point was probably just don't do d5 but
consider d6 instead okay